what up space fam glozen here from anime
uproar and through your likes and
comments i saw how much you guys enjoyed
the relationship videos about tanjiro
and kano and zenito andezuko so i
thought it was about time for the next
one the question was whether i should do
inosuke and aoi next or mitsuri and
iguru and although there were many
requests for both i decided to handle
inosuke first since he is the final
member of the three demon slaying amigos
whose relationship i have yet to cover
that being said i definitely want to do
a video on mitsuri and iguro as well i
absolutely love their love story and if
you guys want to see that too smash that
like button if we can reach 6500 likes
on this one i'll get started on that one
asap if you love demon slayer and have
yet to subscribe i don't know what
you're doing make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications so you
actually get your regular dose of
demonstrator content and while you're
waiting for the new demonstrator video
to drop feel free to check out my huge
and growing playlist that includes
videos on all the hashira demon moons
and much more including like i said a
video on tanjiro and kano's relationship
and zenitsu and nezuko's relationship so
link to that is in the description if
you're cruising through the playlist and
see a video topic that's missing feel
free to leave it as a suggestion for a
future video in the comments below now
without further ado let's jump into its
spoilers and all out of the three main
relationships from the series this one
is probably the one that comes out of
left field the most which is part of
what makes it such an interesting one to
discuss and we'll go into the reasons
why it feels a bit random and why it
isn't so random as we also analyze the
story for clues of inosuke and aoi's
interest in one another inosuke actually
appears to be younger than aoi inosuke
is 15 years old while in the first
demonstrator light novel flower of
happiness aoi reveals that she's older
than the 16 year old kano thus she's
either also 16 and only a few months
older than kano or she's even older than
16. inosuke and aoi have their
similarities and differences the
sometimes girl-faced sometimes
bore-faced inosuke is short-tempered and
aui reveals in the novel that she also
has an impatient personality and we see
that coming through in the manga as well
they both aren't afraid to speak their
mind they can both come off as rude and
they can both be very loud however there
are also differences while inosuke is
introduced to us as someone who loves
fighting with strong opponents and
gathered pride from winning battles aui
was scared of battle and viewed herself
as human trash that was lucky to survive
final selection aoi carried around
feelings of inferiority because she
thought that there was no value to a
squad member who didn't kill demons but
only helped take care of injured squad
members and carried out physical
rehabilitation
we'll get to this in the main story but
in the novel it's also mentioned that
she trembled uncontrollably when the
sound hashtag ordered her to follow him
on a mission so in stark contrast to
inosuke she is most definitely not a
fighter so they have a bit of an
opposite attract thing going on there
thus their division of labor is pretty
traditional she can cook and help take
care of inosuke while he's healing from
his injuries while he can protect her
from physical threats whether human
animal or demon so now that we have a
basic understanding of their
personalities and how they mesh with
each other let's jump into the main
story and search for clues of love aoi
makes her debut in chapter 48 when
tanjiro arrives to the butterfly estate
aui is one of the girls that helps out
there and let's just say she's not shy
if shinobu isn't there aoi is pretty
much the one in charge and what she says
goes since kana who's actually higher
ranking on paper doesn't really respond
or talk to people at this point after
tanja and the demons here help her ask
kanel questions and things get awkward
because she continues to smile without
answering them it's aoi who finally
shows up and breaks attention she has a
commanding presence and this is what i
meant about her not being shy in the
least she screams who the hell are you
to tunjuro and the helper causing them
both to tremble in fear i don't want
this to come off as a negative even
though it tends to have negative
connotations but you could say that very
much like inosuke aoi is a loudmouth
loudmouth refers to someone who tends to
talk a lot in an offensive or tactless
way and that's exactly what we see
happening here that quote-unquote hell
she used in her dialogue wasn't dropped
in there by accident it's there to give
us a sense of her personality which is
very unique among the female characters
of demon slayer we've come to know so
far you can already start to imagine how
loud inosuke and her future home might
be with both of their often aggressive
and loud personalities clashing she goes
on to order tundra and the helpers to
follow her like she's the boss and
starts stomping off another parallel
with inosuke who loves pretending that
he's the boss and tundra and zenitsu are
his underlings when zenitsu is causing
trouble aui tells him to pipe down
frightening him in the process she's the
opposite of a pushover and tells dany2
that if he doesn't behave she'll tie him
down zainsou even starts to cry telling
tundra that he was stabbed and poisoned
by a spider but ali getting angry at him
is even worse it's hard not to
appreciate aoi's strong personality and
no-nonsense approach here she definitely
debuts with a bang and even though she
is suffering from a sense of inferiority
at this point as we'll find out it adds
depth to her character that she can
unabashedly run the show and tell actual
demon slayers what to do without being
the least bit apologetic about it
inosuke in contrast is actually not his
usual self at this point his throat got
crushed and he's depressed just being
quiet in his bed as his great reunion
with tundra is taking place even though
aoi and inosuke were in the same room
here there was no focus on their
relationship no interaction that we can
point to so compared to the zenith going
crazy over seeing nezuko scene and
tundra looking back at kano as the
helpers are taking him away this scene
is interesting and notable because it
doesn't include anything special it
clearly wasn't love at first sight with
these two as far as we can tell which
makes sense when one of the people is
wearing a boar mask after all and since
inosuke is the youngest too it makes
sense that he'd be the last one to
mature and start noticing or thinking
about girls during these butterfly
estate chapters we are told by the
author that there's a rumor that aoi was
the one who repaired nezuko's box we're
told she's got skills as she wears an
angry face but is working on fixing
nezuko's box it captures her character
well she seems like an angry hateful
person sometimes but is actually really
nice sort of like a tsundere unlike
zanitsu inosuke did not enjoy the idea
of girls loosening up his muscles and
getting the chance to grab aoi and kano
in the tag game when zeins was psyched
about the prospect inosuke simply says
and i quote stop talking nonsense losing
to those tiny girls is embarrassing end
quote showing that his mind was
obviously not on girls at this point in
his life unlike
saints who even calls inosuke out for
being naive saying he bets inosuke never
even spent any time with girls before
only for inosuke to misunderstand and
say that he's stepped on plenty of girls
you gotta love it dusk
even though we don't see aoi showing
signs she likes inosuke we do see signs
she doesn't like or appreciate zenitsu's
advances she doesn't like it when
zhangtu holds her hand and beats him up
for grabbing her during tag it's
hilarious to watch because azaitsu is
trying to win her over not even willing
to throw a drink in her face inosuke is
not trying at all he has no qualms about
throwing the drink in her face and even
grabs her by the feet and hangs her
upside down during tag even though all
he had to do was just touch her to win
knowing what we know now all these
earlier parts are absolutely hilarious
ali would go on to develop feelings or
maybe even is developing feelings at
this point for the guy who isn't the
least bit concerned with being nice or
polite to her and i mean to be fair she
isn't too concerned with being polite
herself so it's not that surprising of a
match when the gang is leaving for the
mugen train arc aoi is nice enough
telling tantra that it wasn't long but
she is glad they got to spend time
together and she wishes tenjiro good
luck this is the really sweet moment
where tundra thanks her for taking care
of them and says that it is thanks to
her that he can fight again aoi says
compared to them she's not important so
the thanks is not necessary she survived
final selection due to pure luck and
since then she's been afraid to fight so
she's a coward tundra really gets to her
emotionally when he says that it doesn't
matter that she doesn't fight demons she
helped him so now she's a part of him
he'll think about her when he goes into
battle you can tell by the panel that
she is very touched by tanjiro's words
tundra goes on to talk to kano after
this and kind of actually blushes in the
manga after he leaves while aoi doesn't
it's not romantic with aoi and tanjiro
but it's still a big deal because
tanjore transformed aoi's self-image
here instead of viewing herself as a
coward who is useless and should at the
very least heal people who are her
superiors tundra tells her that her part
or role is just as important and that if
people she saves go on to defeat demons
it's her victory too because she is a
part of them now unfortunately i don't
see nosuke's parting words to ali here
if they did specifically feel the need
to exchange any after all inosuke is his
own beast who doesn't follow usual
conventions and while tundra and zains
are shown tearing up at their parting
with the butterfly estate girls inosuke
is just wearing his mask and we see no
tears you might think he might be crying
but just as a mask on but usually you
actually see tears coming through the
mask when he knows k cries still the
fact that ali uncharacteristically said
she enjoyed spending time with the trio
could be a sign that she liked having
inosuke around specifically too at this
point without knowledge of the future
it's definitely a stretch but knowing
what we know now it could be a clue
after the mugen train arc the gang is at
the butterfly estate again one day
tundra is returning from a solo mission
and this is when he overhears aoi
screams while tangent the sound hashira
is trying to forcefully take her on a
mission she looks very scared and
nervous she sweats as she tells the
hasha who is carrying her to let her go
he even tries to take one of the younger
girls at first who aren't even core
members and accordingly aren't wearing
the demon slang uniforms i briefly
mentioned this part with the sound
pillar near the beginning of the video
but it is really touching here that when
aoi screams out for kano's help kano
actually moves to do something it might
not seem like a big deal at first glance
but if you know her backstory you know
it's a super big deal she sweats a lot
as she thinks about her duty the fact
that tangent is a superior officer and
so on but then she recalls tundra's
advice to obey her heart and that gives
her the strength to grab hold of ali aoi
is brought to tears by the fact that
kano who for a long time just followed
the orders of superiors finally broke
that rule as far as the demonstrator
code goes it appears like tengen is in
his right to do this he implies that he
only needs to ask for shinobu's
permission to take a demonstra graduate
on a mission if she is atsuguko aka the
chosen successor of ahashira thus he
couldn't take khanau without asking
shinobu but he could take aoi official
demonstrator rules aside though everyone
else realizes how wrong he is from an
ethical standpoint and tundra steps in
to help he tries to headbutt tengen but
for once his super effective headbutt
misses because of tangent speed finally
tanjiro insists that if tangent needs
help he'll go instead of ali zainson
nosuke show up at this point and in
those cases before zanito and i quote i
just got back but i'm not tired i don't
mind going either end quote it's not
quite a proclamation of love but
whenever inosuke seems to be doing a
nice thing for someone else you gotta
stop and notice and in this case he does
it on his future wife's behalf their
feelings for each other aren't very
clear yet but the evidence that they
like each other and want to help each
other is slowly growing and it's
probably not lost on aoi here that
inosuke was willing to risk his life on
a dangerous mission to save her from
having to do so it's true that tundra
and zanitsu are willing to do so too but
they're already occupied with butting
love interests like kanou and nezuko now
let's fast forward to chapter 100 after
the trio come back from their upper moon
6 fight kano is by tunjura's side but
aoi isn't she comes in after tundra
wakes up crying because she blames
herself for all of their serious
injuries after all as she points out
they were hurt because they went instead
of her tundra finds out that tangent and
zanitsu's injuries weren't as bad as his
but when he asks about inosuke one of
the butterfly estate girls says he was
in danger for a while too she is not
crying at delivering this news but audi
is crying a lot it's actually quite the
touching panel she says i quote
inosuke's condition was really bad the
poison got deep in him so he was slow to
use breathing to stop the bleeding and
dot dot end quote she doesn't even
finish her sentence before tundra spots
inosuke on the roof this is a
significant moment where we finally get
aoi specifically worrying and crying
about inosuke we can assume that while
kano was by tundra's side the most aoi
was buyingosukes it's clear that no
other girl present had inosuke on her
mind and inner thoughts as much as aoi
did while inosuke calls himself immortal
and one of the little girls calls him
dumb it's aoi who steps in and holds
inosuke back from attacking her she
yells at him saying the poison doesn't
work well on inosuke but neither does
medicine so he has to be careful she
criticizes him for already forgetting
what shinobu told him but her outward
frustration clearly points to her caring
about inosuke after all she wouldn't get
so wound up if she didn't care about
what happened to him inosuke as
hilarious as usual tells aoi to shut up
and to stop pulling on him and even
calls her a shrimp only for her to say
that they aren't that different in
height it's a funny relationship dynamic
between two short-tempered loudmouths
with hearts of gold that's completely
different from the other romantic
relationship dynamics we see in the
series and even though they both act
like tsundere and haven't confessed
their feelings for each other after this
there is good reason to ship them
besides just the fact that the other
characters are already shipped with each
other aoi was deeply affected by his
injuries and continues to get emotional
about it even though he's fine now and
continues to care about him warning him
that he needs to be careful despite him
continuing to be rude to her as usual
and one can also assume that they
wouldn't care to bicker with each other
so much if they had no feelings for each
other it's been said that the opposite
of love is not hate but indifference and
these two are definitely not indifferent
with one another we also find out during
shinobu's fight against doma that aoi's
family was killed by demons just like
inosuke's mother was killed by a demon
namely doma it's significant that
inosuke helped defeat doma since it was
revenge for his mother but it was also
revenge for shinobu one of the most
important people in aoi's life now let's
fast forward to after the world is saved
from the demon king of pop inosuke and
aoi get another telling scene inosuke is
walking around the estate thinking about
how hungry he is he starts stealing food
while aoi is cooking and she calls him
out for it inosuke lies but wonders how
she notices so fast
and that maybe she's strong which is
definitely a plus in inosuke's books and
then we get an adorable part where aoi
gives inosuke his own plate and says
that when he's hungry he can eat from it
this plate will just be for him so he
can eat from it whenever he wants to the
implication is that she'll keep
refilling it and making special meals
for inosuke inosuke this time is the one
who stares at aoi and blushes he looks
down at the food and you see possibly
the cutest smile in the series plastered
on his face finally we have hard
evidence that inosuke is into aoi too
and that the way into his heart is
through his stomach then all that's left
is the confirmation that they end up
together and we get this in the form of
aoba hashibira the great grandson of
inosuke and aoi even before it was
officially confirmed that aoi was the
great grandmother it was suggested since
the allah in alba seem to come from the
awa in aoi then there's the new more
detailed ending they included in the
final demonstrator volume that gives us
some scenes that fill in some of the
gaps between chapter 204 and chapter
205. there's even one panel that shows
what looks like inosuke presenting his
idea of a gift which seems to be some
stuff he just scavenged from nature to
ali and ali being genuinely touched to
receive it it appears to be a bit of a
throwback to inosuke's dream during the
mugen train arc 2 where he presents
nezuko with some acorns and says and i
quote look i'll give you these sparkly
acorns come on end quote he clearly
associates it with it being a nice
gesture and with it being a way to get
people to come with him our manly boy
has legit started to act like zanytu
who's always picking flowers for nezuko
we also get a bit of info on their
great-grandson alba here like daddy's
28th lost his job plays badminton with
tundra and connell's descendant and has
one little brother and that is it
although it was the least focused on
relationship of the big three i hope i
showed how it didn't come from nowhere
and there were subtle clues earlier on
that these two may well end up together
aside from just their at times
strikingly similar personalities i
genuinely love these two as a couple and
aoi definitely brought out some of
inosuke's cutest moments which is saying
a lot since inosuke tends to be manly
more often than cute but yeah i drop a
ship it or skip it in the comments to
let me know if you are a fan of this
couple if you did enjoy this video you
know what to do smash that like button
if we can reach 6500 likes on this one i
repeat
6500 i'll get cert on the next one asap
which will probably be about mitsuri and
iguro that's definitely an epic love
story if you love demon slayer and have
yet to subscribe what are you doing make
this the video you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications so you actually get your
regular dose of demonstrator content and
while you're waiting for the new
demonstrator video to drop feel free to
check out my huge and growing playlist
that includes videos on all the hashida
demon moons and much more link to that
is in the description if you're cruising
through this playlist and see a video
topic that's missing feel free to leave
it as a suggestion for a future video in
the comments below and i especially
wanted to thank the patron squad over on
patreon and here on youtube who helped
make videos like this one possible first
and foremost i want to thank the patron
of legend the one acknowledged by lord
tuigo himself alpha sigma and other one
to your patrons the ones who stand on
top all clans ingrata al jatal pate
heffa the red haired fox hinokami and
water the toasted tree corey mcgowan the
spike dylan isadore spidey life chanel
tungsten targets big buddhist monkey d
quilly cody hebert and jeremy cummings
and are pro hero to your patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel crews
very gucci alicia actor bonnie parks
joanne garcia fat boy games kaido might
be a duck jessica rabbit and jeremy
phillips thank you all so much if you're
also a fan who enjoys our work you can
directly support more of it by going
over to patreon.com anime pro and
becoming a patron today for as little as
one dollar if you do so you'll get your
name featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course the dank memes
so check out patreon.com anime upload
link in the description if you're
interested you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue join
button next to the subscribe button that
you've hopefully already destroyed so
yeah you can support more content that
way if you prefer whichever way to
support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you